leute es ist eine weile her dass ich
mich in einem video an euch gerichtet
habe um genau zu sein drei tage
und ja ich muss ich sagen dass ich eben
den letzten drei tagen ohne es wirklich
zu merken oder schweige den zu wollen
eine sucht entwickelt habe und wovon
anderes könnte ich sprechen als von
pokémon leute die letzten tage ist ding
einfach überhaupt nicht klar ich habe so
viele pokemon gefangen und soviel
pokémon go zeug gemacht ihr müsst wissen
ich habe jetzt seit kurzem einen abitur
und habe im moment wirklich nichts zu
tun
übrigens ist natürlich nicht der grund
weshalb keine videos kam das hat andere
gründe aber darauf werde ich später auch
noch mal eingehen also pokémon go hat
komplett meine freizeit eingenommen und
meine freizeit ist im moment so ziemlich
alles mein bester kumpel der eigentlich
studiert ist zurzeit zu hause bei seinen
eltern und das ist bei mir in der stadt
und wir haben uns pokémon gold zusammen
runtergeladen und leute wirklich ich
feiere dieses spiel zu tode
zum ersten wirklich richtig krass also
mega cooles spiel und wir haben so viel
gesuchte also ihr müsst wissen ich an
mein bester kumpel wir sind schon immer
gerne draußen unterwegs gewesen und
waren immer gern mal eine runde laufen
oder sogar das auf komplett neue ausmaße
getrieben
ich habe mit pokémon go in den letzten
drei tagen 248 poker stopps besucht ich
bin 31,1 kilometer gelaufen ich habe 116
pokémon allein vom typ normal gefangen
ich habe 69 pokémon vom typ käfer
gefangen und ich habe 26 pokémon vom typ
wasser gefangen
also alles in allem da man ja
herumlaufen muss um die pokémon zu
fangen könnt ihr euch vorstellen wie
viel ich unterwegs war aber ich habe
auch relativ schnell gelevelt also falls
ihr noch mal ein
tipps und tricks video sehen wollt dann
könnt ihr mich das gerne mal wissen
lassen
dann zeige ich euch es kommt ja auch
bald offiziell in deutschland raus wie
ihr am schnellsten erfolgreich werde und
nun richtig guter trainer seit in
pokémon go also lasst mich das wissen
außerdem habe ich 15 level gemacht
innerhalb dieser drei tage für
diejenigen die das spielen
das ist relativ viel könnt ihr glaube
ich bestätigen aber es hat richtig spaß
gemacht so leute ich zeig euch jetzt mal
meine pokemon die ich bisher so gefangen
habe ich dachte das mache ich heute
einfach mal so ein bisschen um zu
checken okay habt ihr bock auf pokémon
go hinter überhaupt ausmacht euch spaß
generell pokémon weil ich herr pokemon
immer gefeiert wobei ich wirklich wenige
edition gespielt hat meistens habe ich
die feuerrote gespielt habe ich glaube
ich viermal durchgezockt oder so zwei
mal auf dem gameboy und locker zwei mal
auf dem emulator mit dem handy auf dem
handy mit dem emulator so rum ich zeige
euch mal was ich so viel pokémons am
start habe also zu beginn natürlich mein
ganzer stolz
flamatt 816 bp ich kann mir auch das
nächste bully ist eine entwicklung von
goalie favre kann ich mir wieder
entwickeln wenn ich noch fangen würde
dann haben wir hier meine bietak 545
habe ich genauso gefangen
lustigerweise habe ich die meisten
meiner guten vogel pokémon direkt
gefangen als nächstes sehen wir das auch
genauso gefangen
das habe ich in der arena drittplatziert
bis war mein drittbestes pokémon
viertbestes pokémon sehr spektakulär
auch ein taubes aber dafür wird es noch
mal meister beim fünften und zwar ist
das mein mascher 480p habe ich genauso
gefangen auch schon in der arena
platziert 71 kp hat das ding also es ist
richtig krass und ich hoffe mal dass ich
den wald entwickeln kann am global
boxing glaubt relativ schwer zu kriegen
dann noch meine bietak auch so gefangen
ja ich weiß irgendwie kann ich habe viel
glück dass ich immer die finalen
entwicklung von den ganzen fange aber
ich glaube das ist bei den los gar nicht
so falsch
also die einzigen coolen pokémon die ich
bisher habe auf einem hohen level
zumindest in flammen
und mach rollo ich habe zwar noch ein
zwei ganz coole die sind aber nicht auf
so ein megaphon level so ihr seht ihr
schon lieber mag ich sie persönlich als
gerne aber ist jetzt nicht so special
dann europe war relativ selten bisher
die kopie saß am start habe ich einfach
gefangen voll krass so hier nebels
relativ hoch ist habe ich gefangen dann
habe ich rossana aus einem ei bekommen
ja und außerdem noch abra und flug aber
ansonsten war es das mit den seltenen ok
pumpe luft noch aber wieviel 34 das sind
auf jeden fall so meine pokémon die ich
bisher am start habe aber wirklich von
tag zu tag kriegt einfach viel bessere
ist unglaublich gestern war mein bestes
pokémon noch wp 300
und mittlerweile ja jetzt gesehen das
macht auf jeden fall mega viel spaß
so und jetzt wollte ich natürlich noch
erzählen was der eigentliche grund ist
dass ich keine videos mache und der ist
relativ dorf eigentlich und zwar der
vielleicht gemerkt dass mein kanal
richtig gut ab ging also ich habe viele
abos gemacht folgt wie die klicks
gemacht das ist natürlich sehr
motivieren wenn man das so sieht
als youtube und der konnte ich da
produziert habt war auch content hinter
dem ich 100 prozent gestanden habe ich
hab die die videos gefeiert die alleine
gemacht habe und vor allem habe ich die
videos gefeiert die ich mit anderen
youtuber gemacht habe jetzt aber das
problem dass ich relativ wenige videos
alleine gemacht habe um genau zu sein
die kommentare serie habe ich da alleine
gemacht und die anderen videos fand ich
immer richtig cool also mit luca dass
meine freundin lucy dann ekel beer pong
und solche sachen
es hat so viel spaß gemacht aber das
problem ist da ist immer jemand zweites
dabei ich habe eine liste gemacht weil
ich wollte nicht wieder keine videos
produzieren und in dieser liste stehen
15 videos die ich machen möchte alles
ideen von mir selbst ich mir überlegt
habe die cool sind die ein gutes video
abgeben würden
nix irgendwie geklaut oder so aber jede
von diesen ideen braucht jemand zweites
und das ist so ein bisschen das problem
also ich wohne halt in der nähe von
frankfurt also nicht in direkter nähe
aber es sind einfach keine leute mit dem
ich etwas zu tun haben mit denen keine
videos mache in der nähe mit dem video
machen könnte und dass so ein bisschen
ein problem also mich würd's sowieso in
den nächsten monaten nach köln ziehen
denke ich mal war ich habe jetzt wie
gesagt mein abitur und köln ist halt
einfach es also gewohnt luca da wohnt in
der nähe meine freundin und es spricht
sehr vieles dafür dass ich dorthin
ziehen dann werden sich dafür natürlich
möglichkeiten bilden und es ist zwar
möglich zusammen videos aufzunehmen so
wie ich das jetzt mit meinem bruder
gemacht hatte über facetime und
gleichzeitig die kamera aufnehmen
aber optimal ist das wirklich alles
nicht und da hat auch nicht jeder bock
drauf mit dem ich ein video machen
möchte ja das ist so ein bisschen meine
geschichte der letzten tage gewesen
heute gibt es dafür wieder video aptn
ich mal wieder vor der kamera gesehen
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
ich bin zufrieden eigentlich also mich
persönlich wird es voll interessieren
aber ich suchte das spiel auch in der
letzten zeit ok wurde aber ich hoffe es
hat euch gefallen lassen um einen like
darf als das getan hat und schreibt mir
die kommentare ob wir einen tipps und
tricks video sehen wollt kann ich auch
ex zeigen die ich gefunden aber ich habe
selbst nicht benutze ich schwöre weil
die machen das spiel kaputt
ok